hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to Episode seven of network chat
programming so I am back home in
Melbourne Australia which feels awesome
so hopefully these videos will be a bit
more often even though I do have
University and other responsibilities
here I do have a decent upload speed and
it could freakin connection to the
internet that I have to pay a lot of
money for so that means that there
should be more videos anyway straight to
it so right now if we just launched our
program here and put something in for
the port so it doesn't crash hit login
and we get this is what we've got so far
actually type here and this uses the
grid bag layout so you can see kind of
resizes weirdly when you fix that up
obviously but you can see that when we
actually go past the width it doesn't
our characters don't um actually
remember as you guys can see probably
the characters actually stopped so it
was what's happening is it's resizing
the actual text area okay so that's all
cool but um let's take a look at how we
can actually utilize grid back layer
properly with the different weights so
that we resize everything properly and
add more components so first thing I
want to do is actually copy this UI
manager code to UM to right over here
because we didn't do that and I will
import that and that'll actually
unimportant that we had imported that we
didn't need so that works out nicely
um one more thing I want to mention is
mu merge K actually pointed out the
create window was a it was
unconventional to call it because I'm
calling something from the constructor
but it's alright because it's private
which means that no one's going to
override this method at all because it's
private you can't actually override you
could probably over it within this class
but we're not going to be doing it but
it is private so that's one thing to
make sure I feel doing that too to
prevent you know future embarrassment by
pointing that out am i right okay so
yeah so in other words it's all right to
call um this method from the constructor
because it's not you can't override
anyway so how does this actually work
let's just add a few more components so
that we can see really what we're
dealing with fire switch over to design
you'll see what I mean
okay cool so we've got our design here
what I want to do is add more buttons
essentially so I'm just going to grab a
J button pop it like right over here you
can see that we get this massive button
here in a minute and we'll just call it
our send yeah that'll be like our send a
button we don't want it to be here we
want it to be over there right so what
we need to do is actually make a space
for it and we'll actually probably have
to do that through card I'm not sure how
to do that with um window builder but
that's all I wouldn't need to really do
through code so the way that I want to
do this is um essentially add a the
why's good right the Y is good but I
think the UM the X is what we really
need to change so in the column widths
we've got this massive column column
here that is actually 857 pixels wide we
might want to split that up and Cilicia
say okay so we'll split it up let's just
say we leave like I don't know 30 or so
pixels for the button let see what that
looks like so I'm gonna subtract 30 from
there and add it as another parameter
here and not another parameter but
another integer here into the array and
in grid X I'm actually going to change
that to 2 so in other words 0 over here
in grid X 0 and grid X corresponds to
the first index in this array 1
corresponds to the second one and 2
corresponds to the third one and of
course 4 corresponds to the fourth 3rd 3
sorry corresponds to the 4th one but of
course arrays start with 0 so 0 1 2 & 3
that's how it works so if I go to let's
just switch over design here what we
should see is our button in a different
area here now what what happens here is
that our texture actually gets resized
so if I actually launch this so you guys
can see this a bit better you can see
that we've kind of achieved more or less
what we want but not really because this
text area now doesn't actually it
doesn't actually appear here yet we want
it to so how do we how do we change
that's another thing we got to look at
and let's just take a look at what do we
want to do we'll also add one more
component here a a text field we'll add
it right over here at the very bottom
here we'll call it um I got a no message
maybe and then we'll get rid of the text
here I called a message again just so
called variable message otherwise it
wouldn't know what call it um and it's
assigned a to pretty good spot so let's
take a look at that five okay so now you
can see we've more or less got this is
actually a perfect space right here with
what our send button up here and we've
got our text area that we kind of need a
resize so let's take a look at how we
can do this column weights um is to do
with resizing weight is generally to do
with resizing but what we really need to
take a look at here is um the width and
the height okay so what we need to do is
make a grid width essentially so what
we've got over here is our text area
which we want to actually if I just move
this like an demonstrate to you guys
what's up
we want this a text area here to span
multiple grid cells right we can see
that we've got multiple results we just
look at this we've got this one right
here we've got this one here you can
actually see the dividers here we've got
this here we've got this area here and
we want this area here we essentially
want um our our text area to not only
encompass this cell but also this one we
want to span it across these two cells
how do we do that now you could probably
just drag it across just like that you
can see that works but I'm going to show
you guys how to do it through code just
because it's useful so what we want to
do is we want to grab this text history
variable and we want to add a new we
want to set a another variable here
manually called grid width yeah and grid
with well actually if this comes up in
the job doc weren't yet let's just set
it to zero for now so we can see
okay actually I don't have salsa - but
what grid with does is that actually
specifies how many cells is component
will take up so one is the default one
is just one cell but if we put it to two
and run it and put a poor word in here
what we'll actually get is as you can
see this this text area now spans both
of these cells which is awesome and this
is actually looking pretty good right
now okay I'm not complaining it's sort
of pretty good we've got our send button
we've got um this thing Zen button look
slightly above the texts are the text
field it's not actually above it it's
just a bit it's just not as high so we
might want to make this button a bit
larger um we'll do that in a minute
certainly but um it also looks like our
tax area here is just a bit too far so I
might just subtract the width here so
the width of our text error is currently
set to actually have no idea where are
we what is it set to where do we set it
um let's see text area where do we set
the UM oh yeah of course
when I said that manually um okay so
let's um let's just set this to probably
about if we just add it add seven to it
so if we add if we change 23 we can
probably subtract it from here and see
what that looks like there's really not
much in sets we might add some inserts
to it to fix that if the sum destroys at
the look yeah so that's kind of working
here but it's still not good enough so
let's maybe move this down to 15 in this
up to 28 as long as it adds up to 880
you can do pretty much anything with
these to make it a bit better okay I'm
definitely going to add some in sets so
to add in sets which you can see we
actually our button has inserts here but
we can add in sets and those are
essentially just really minor
adjustments just to a specific component
in the grid back layout so if we go down
here
pick up our variable here and if we say
the inserts equal to new oops equal to
new in sets and we probably want let's
just try it let's just so we can
obviously see it 20 right and we're on
this well that's going to do predictably
is insert us by 20 I believe I'm not
sure which direction that is if we just
try let's just try all directions
definitely not one direction you can see
that it inserts it in all directions I
thought that this one would be X but
it's going on so I think if by this
logic I honestly have no idea this could
be a million different things let's just
take a look at if we leave it over there
all right so that's the bottom so I
guess this would be DV um left if it's
going clockwise I don't know no that's
the right okay so it's this one I guess
okay
confusing um so yeah okay so let's just
insert this by probably about five
pixels or so and see what that looks
like
so in sets are pretty much padding I'm
just padding this by by five pixels that
looks so that's perfect actually
okay so we'll leave it at that um so
that's pretty much what our thing will
look like a few adjustments I want to
make is first of all the size of our
button so if we take a look at this now
buttons pretty much the same sizes and
it should be the same size of this this
is just slightly um I think the deal is
that text messages the boxes just bigger
I'm not sure it looks pretty good to me
though so I'm going to live with that
but what I wanted to do was make this
non editable because this is our um this
thing here if I just log in again this
thing here is our um message history we
definitely don't want that to be
editable and when we we just want to
send stuff to it we don't want people to
be
when I want people to copy and paste
from it that's fine we'll allow that but
we don't want people to type stuff into
it and then when we do actually log in
we want this field over here to be
selected by default so the people can
type in straightaway and hit enter to
send or hit the send button of course
just so it looks a bit better so let's
do that
to make this non editable we simply need
to uncheck the editable box this is how
easy window builder gives it to us
anyway if we take a look at the source
code what is done is it's simply set
editable to false for the text area and
then what we can do here now at the very
end I like to do is at the very end we
text message is our arm field we can
actually just pull the focus thing again
because it's that nice and so focus is
it is request focus so I completely
forgot that we can just request focus on
that component so if we run this again
see that as soon as I log in we can
actually type here no I can't
okay so what's up with that there are a
few arm this is why I like to do it at
the very end there are a few little
quirks here with request focus which
probably request focus to the actual
component first to the big thing first
take a look at that and know okay
sometimes this is operating system
dependent and not really working but
we'll figure out the request focus stuff
probably in a later episode but other
than that we shouldn't be able to edit
this anymore
right we can only type here okay so that
is episode 7 of an arrow programming
we're going to take a look at actual lip
um now why code probably not next
episode of episode after because I want
to cover these stuff about actually
getting style and maybe and probably I'm
sending it to the message history but
anyway if you enjoyed this episode
please hit the like button I'll see you
guys next time with a brand new episode
of networks chapter at browning see you
guys later bye
you